and I want to start by thanking Richard
and Barbara Frankie who end out the
Frankie program that have made events
like this possible I'm actually
delighted that we are recording this
because as you all know this is part of
a new Frankie program contest and
competition that we have announced
called Eureka and we are absolutely
delighted to have as avera who is an
award-winning producer and director with
a doctorate in molecular biology so
she's a scientist by training and but
had a real passion for capturing
extraordinary stories that share the
complexity of the natural world and the
latest scientific advances and she
wanted to bring it to global audiences
so she's very very accomplished
documentary filmmaker
she started her professional career in
filmmaking and storytelling via phone
visually in 2005 and her talents have
been quickly recognized by top
broadcasters these international
production companies and media agencies
she has created many very successful
documentaries and shows for TV short
films doctors and content platforms and
the reach of her work is over 1 billion
viewers so she really has enormous reach
enormous influence and impact and she is
a recipient I just don't have the time
because I'm really curious to hear what
she has to tell us about storytelling
but she's the recipient of over 30
international awards including the
bronze world medal at the New York
festival's of TV and film as well as
many accolades for the innovative visual
effects that she incorporates into her
cinematography including AR and VR
augmented reality and virtual reality
videos and experiences she's worked on
interactive websites on educational apps
for the iPad to enrich experiences for
the audience and her clients are
numerous they include yahood n2 Vodafone
BBVA RTV and L pious and many other
media platforms she holds a PhD in
molecular biology from the University of
Nevada
in Spain and a master's degree in
communications and film from Pompeu
Fabra University in Barcelona and her
education and years of experience both
being a scientist working in the lab
experience experiencing what it means to
do science and how to communicate the
exciting discoveries that are made in
the lab that really enables her to bring
a unique and very authentic experience
and perspective to storytelling and this
has allowed her to become a real master
compelling teller of stories and we are
really honored to have her not just give
us some tips and tricks but help us
learn about what it really takes to tell
a compelling story and this is something
that is going to be of great use so I
just although the audience today looks
very slim I wanted to reassure her and
all of you that we had tens and tens of
people get it get to us asking if this
will be videotaped so because of the
weather today I think most people have
decided that they're gonna watch this
later on from the recording and before
we move on to today's event I just
wanted to announce a couple of upcoming
events because we have a very busy week
next week we have a distinguished
lecturer we have the senior editor of
the Atlantic magazine Ross Anderson who
is going to be visiting and speaking on
Monday February 24th and then we have on
Wednesday we have mathematician and
novelist Zia had a Ramon with whom I
will be having a conversation on stage
on Wednesday evening February 26th and
then part of them mapping as knowing
lecture series at the end of March we
have a musicologist am a pair of music
Viktor Coelho who will be speaking and
we have a distinguished lecturer event
Susan Hockfield the former president of
MIT and former Provost of Yale and April
13 so we just have a whole bunch of
exciting events coming up and most
importantly as part of this Eureka
contest
zubaba has dr. Marcos has really agreed
and it's an honor that she's part of our
jury for this contest which is now
opened we had a lot of interest in
excitement
so originally we were gonna open it only
to the Yale community staff students and
faculty but Yale alumni wanted in so the
contest is now actually totally open to
the public and anyone who can send a
video clip that is less than two minutes
explaining a scientific concept in a
very unique way without using
mathematics or jargon is welcome to
submit and so our distinguished jury
will do the selection and we'll have a
final screening on April 21st so mark
your calendars so it is my utter
pleasure to invite Subaru to come and
tell us more about how to tell a
compelling story and in particular a
compelling story that involves science
discoveries in science and the process
of doing science so player thank you so
much for the invitation for me it so we
suppressor to participate in any
initiative that put together science
with the humanities so thank you and I
also think you to the ones that made it
here despite the rain and the weather so
before any start I would love to get a
sense who I'm speaking to
so what's the audience here are you
scientists are you filmmakers are you
researchers who are you we're a small
audience and actually I love that so who
are you say who who is a scientist okay
and the ones that are not scientists
oh my god I don't know if I'm going to
teach you anything that you don't know
we're ready okay great
you're an architect okay wonderful
and the scientists in which field are
you working psychologists okay great
Wow astrophysics wonderful
so one thing at the end of the of this
conversation I will share with Priya a
documentary the same document that I
have now in my hands that has everything
that I'm going to explain here
everything and it's way more detail that
I'm going to say so you don't have to
take notes actually I will prefer if for
me it's more important that especially
because it's a small group and it's
really easy to interact if you ask me
questions I know the jury's a special
Q&A time at the end of the of the talk
but for me it's more important and I
welcome to you and encourage you
actually to ask me questions through the
presentation I'm more interested in
answering your questions than in going
through all my slides okay so please
feel free to interrupt me and ask me
questions so the goal of these small
talk is to walk you through what I have
learned over the past 15 years producing
different kind of multimedia products
from films to short films to suriya's
etc so when we talk about science
communication also called popularization
what we mean is it's an effort to reduce
the distance that it exists between
science and the common knowledge and in
order to do that well usually we have to
do is to take that scientific knowledge
and transform it in a way there is more
aligned to how people understand
the reason we have to do that is and
this is also painful for me is because
for most of the people science is not
among the most interesting things so we
have to make it appealing in some ways
and in order to do that there are some
techniques and there are some resources
that I'm going to explain today that
actually if we use them it can help us
overcoming that distance and closing
that gap a basic rule not only for
science communication but for any kind
of communication is know what know who
your audience is and respect your
audience take care of your audience
that's critical
that means communicate with them don't
teach them it's very easy especially
when you are doing science communication
to give a lecture the same thing that
you give in a class to give it on a
phone and actually when people sit in
the living room towards a documentary or
a film they want to be entertained so
that's something that you always have to
keep in mind when you are thinking on
creating something multimedia
communicate with people don't teach them
the next thing is be respectful with
feelings and also this is particularly
important in science because there are
topics that people are afraid of saying
for example on CRISPR CRISPR is this
technique that allows us to engineer
genes and with that to play with life so
instead of putting yourself in a
position of I'm a scientist
trust me actually embrace that I mean
show respect towards the people that are
watching you by a no lydian that
actually that topic is dangerous okay
and the third thing is never forget and
we are going to go back to these over
the talked several times never forget
the human element so in science usually
science usually the scientist
method separates the site scientists as
individuals from the research in
communication the human element is the
most important thing not just because
scientists are at the end humans but
also because the connection between
people happens at an emotional level you
are not going to connect with a person
through facts it's really hard to do
that but you are going to connect
through the emotions too so you have to
always keep in mind that human
connection and every single time that
you are going to tell a story about
science try to find something that
resonates with the soul of your audience
that's really critical and again this
applies to every single way of
communication whether is science or not
science I'm going to focus in the word
that I've learned myself I started my
career doing broadcast TV then I switch
into digital and I have done digital TV
and serious for the for a different
theater media outlets so TV theater
mobile devices anything there is video
it has its own characteristics and the
main thing is now this has changed a
little bit but TV has always been a
one-pass medium that means that you
could not when you sat in your living
room and you were watching a documentary
you could not just a stop think what you
just saw and then continue now this has
changed especially with the streaming
platforms now with Netflix with Amazon
Prime with YouTube you we can do
actually that but that's something that
is still a major characteristic of
television or video and has to be I mean
you have to think about that the other
thing is the way TV communicate thing is
radically different to science in TV we
love using narrative
that are poetic and that are dramatic if
you think of science science is always
very intellectual it's very theoretical
it's a way I mean it loves explaining
things in a very organized structural
way TV is yes the opposite and they the
reason for that is because at the end as
I already said what we want is to build
a human connection and in order to do
that we need to reveal the stories so
that's another main characteristic of TV
and the last one that I will say is it's
a medium that is not good to convey a
lot of information so every single time
that you want to tell something through
a video actually you are not going to be
able to explain more than one or two
ideas so actually it's really important
to choose before you study when shooting
and we will go further into this what is
what you are gonna tell so every single
film that you do needs a storyline so
the storyline is the plot and is
basically what holds your audience
interested and keeps them interested
through the length of your production
until the end so the storyline of a
documentary for example is something
that is decided early on in the
production process and usually defines
the whole production and especially the
content that is going to be included in
that in that production because
everything that is not aligned with that
storyline usually is going to be left
aside obviously in order to be a
storyline well there are different way
there are different type of storylines
there are serious that I'm sorry because
that eye is too small and I think you
cannot even read what is written there
so no worries I
I tell you that so there are different
type of story lines there are multi
episodic series that have a common story
line for example think all think of the
wildlife funds some of them they tackle
how life evolved on planet earth or the
different species that lives on planet
earth some of those series each episode
has its own story line think of we are
going to devote an episode to Antarctica
think of a serious that wants to explain
that most representative animals that
live in each continent so we have a main
story line each episode has its own
story line and then in with them each
episode we can find also a smaller story
lines that is what we call sequences
imagine that we are again working on a
film about the species in Antarctica and
we want to shoot a whale that lives in
Antarctica
so that and they be a particular
behavior of a whale that lives in
Antarctica so that will be a specific
storyline so we have different types of
storylines and depending on the
production that we are working on if we
are doing a two three minutes long video
as the ones for the you Rica film
competition usually we will choose just
one storyline if we are working in
something bigger probably will have to
deal with different storylines at
different levels obviously in order to
build a storyline the first thing is to
decide what we are going to talk about
right what is the the story that we are
gonna tell and one of the main mistakes
is to mix a topic with a story what
topic and what's a story so let's
imagine that we want to create a film
that explains time trouble through
wormholes all we want to create a form
that explains the revival of extinct
species through genetic engineering okay
those will be topics a topic to be a
story
it needs a plot so the true topic that I
just mentioned to you are actually the
topics behind two major scientific
movies do you recognize them right
okay so interstellar I chose these
movies on purpose because I thought that
almost all or everyone who I mean knows
them so interstellar is about that it's
about time travel through a wormhole
right and you're a sick park is about
genetic engineering and how to bring
back to life species that don't exist
anymore so how did the producers and the
director turned that topic into a story
in the case of interstellar the story is
at a time with life on Earth is under
threat there is this group of astronauts
that leave everything behind and trouble
- through a wormhole near Saturn trying
to find a new home that's the story in
the case of Jurassic Park what the story
is what happens with an amusement park
full of cloned animals collapses it
shows the dangers of messing up with
mother nature right so the common theme
of the stories all the stories have
three things together they have
characters they have conflict and they
have timeliness if we go back again to
interstellar the characters are the
group of astronauts the conflict is life
on Earth has become extremely difficult
so we need to find another place and we
need to find that place before we all
die
right and the timeliness is the same
thing right so when you are looking for
a story look for a story that has
characters that has timeliness and that
has a conflict I know this is easier
said than done
so how can you a way of figuring out
when you think about an idea for example
for the Eureka Film Festival to figure
out if you have a topic or you have a
story you can ask yourself these five
questions so can I communicate it in a
single sentence consisting of nouns what
I said
time travel through wormholes to
different worlds that's something that's
a topic is it time-sensitive then
definitely it's going to be a story does
it contain characters that are easy to
identify definitely is going to be a
story
can I pinpoint the conflict again is
going to be a story it's heavy on themes
in short in details what do you think
you're going to be if something is heavy
on themes short in details it's going to
be a topic right so asking yourself
these questions actually is going to
help you figure out if what you have is
a topic or it's a story the next thing
will be okay how do I know once I have a
story if it is a good a story because
that's also critical when you are
working on a film or in a movie or
whatever so what I will suggest is think
of if you will feel compelled to tell
that story to a group of friends having
a drink or enjoy in a barbecue if you
feel compelled to do that and be
provocative and at the same time be
factual I mean to stick to the facts but
at the same time try to simplify it then
you have a story
if not probably it's not a good story I
mean if not maybe it's not the best one
but you can also ask yourself questions
to test how good is your story and for
me the most important one is that's the
story challenge what we know about that
topic that means in other words is that
a story surprising in any way surprise
is one of the most powerful ways of
attract people's attention so if you
have something surprising if you have
something intriguing that's definitely a
really good story why should be you will
scare about this this is a good one
because when we are thinking about the
stories we are bias we usually think
about the stories on topics or subjects
that are interesting for us but
something that is interesting for us
doesn't necessarily it's not necessarily
interesting for all the people so a good
way of testing this is again and I know
this is not very scientific but going
back to your friends or to relatives on
and actually share your idea with them
and see what your response you don't
have to even ask them to tell you
something with words even the reaction
registered is going to tell you if
that's a good a story of it's not and
the last question is why is this story
important and why it's important now so
asking yourself these questions will
help you figure out if you have a really
good story once you have a story then
you have to do the research and
basically the goal of the research is to
learn as much as you can about that
topic depending on the production that
you are doing this period of time can
take a few days can take weeks it can
take even months or even years of doing
the research and basically is in this
stage where you are going to put your
reporter heart hat on
you are going to start with in papers
gathering facts figuring out who are the
main players in the field making calls
trying to get all the leads and facts
you can about the subject of your story
so my recommendation is when you are
doing your research to write down the
main and ideas that you find because
that will help you then put them in a
sequence and actually build your story
line once you have done the research
another important element is to make a
shortlist think of the shortlist as the
ingredients that you need in order to
make your film right so when you are
thinking on the shortlist
there are several things that you have
to keep in mind the first one is do you
have pre-existing footage or images for
us that are going to help you tell your
story yes or no do you have to shoot
everything yourself brand new that's the
main theme that's a very important thing
actually when planning a production
another one is who are do you know who
are your primary characters do you know
the people that you are going to
interview do you know the people that
are going to be in your phone the
landmarks landmarks are essential in any
phone think about the places that you
want to base it and you wanna shoot in
every film there will be places that
have a strong connection with the
characters in the film or with the
subject in the film so if you can go to
any of those places that's a very
powerful way of building something there
is deep and there is engaging then think
about the activities that you are that
you need to shoot so let's think that we
are making a film about a marine
biologist
that is a study in a group of whales
going back to the same example that we
used before so I need to go to
Antarctica to film those whales because
they only live there so when planning on
their activities to film for that movie
you could include the preparations to go
to Antarctica the trip to Antarctica
then they have to devote they need to
prepare the boat they need to approach
the whales in a way that doesn't they
start the whales they need to prepare
their materials I mean some of the
behaviors in the animal world you can
only see them from a bulb so now we have
for example tools like drones that allow
us to get really beautiful footage from
from the sky so you could include you
shoot the scientists working on
preparing that then how actually how
they quickly respond when suddenly the
whales appear and I start behaving and
doing whatever thing it is and obviously
at the end you will have also that the
footage actually that what you wanna do
that the behavior that you wanna shoot
so plan all the activities don't just
focus on the outcome I think one of the
main mistakes that we make is we show
science at something that happens by
magic one of the one of the main
mistakes that we make is that we show
science as something that happens like
my egg and any person that works in
science in the in a lab knows that
actually science is a process and it's a
process with many ups and downs so
actually is in that process when you are
going to find also the more emotional
elements of the story and the ones that
are going to help you build that
connection with your audience so
definitely don't forget about them and
the last one is are you filming
something that involves an activity with
a specific timeline so are you filming
an eclipse
let's say and that eclipse is gonna
happen at a specific date and time or
are you filming something that is not
time-sensitive and then you can recreate
that for example you are filming
something that's that's a picture of a
documentary that I did about Roman
engineering I mean we had to build from
scratch the Roman world the ancient wall
so we have to design from scratch the
whole thing so thinking about all those
elements it's really important so once
you have done all your research you are
the super expert in your subject and do
you have a very detailed shot glass of
what do you need to make your movie is
the time to start thinking on the script
and the structure of the script most
science documentaries are unscripted and
then people ask and how do you make
something there is unscripted all the
reasons that you do usually serves you
as a guideline to plan the story and to
plan the different shots and do you let
the final story emerge as you film that
said there are like two main schools
here so there are filmmakers that love
to use all the information that they
gather doing the research to create like
a preliminary treatment or a script and
then they go out there and they start
filming and then in the editing room
they update that script with the real
footage and then there are other set of
filmmakers that actually gather the
information get a deep understanding on
the subject they assemble the crews and
they go out and they start filming and
at the end of the day they will review
all the footage they will select the
most powerful clips and they will start
assembling them and building the story
letting
a story and March none of them is better
or worse I mean I know producers
something makers that operate both ways
I think it's more a personal decision
that something that is bad or good
right or wrong but when you are building
the script there are in order to give
your story a good structure there are
several guidelines that is good to
follow I will say to focus on the
opening the opening is the most critical
part of your film because it's when your
audience is going to decide if they are
going to keep with you or they are going
to move on to another thing and that
decision is going to happen in few
seconds so in the opening you have to
choose something that it's really
compelling and it can be compelling
because as we said is surprising because
it's intriguing or because it's
something new I mean you can play with
many things also one of the main
strengths when you are working with
video is that you have the words what
people actually are saying but you also
have the footage the image that you have
and you have the sense and you can play
with all of them or you can play yes
with some of them I mean me you say we
will see later it's a very powerful tool
to create tension to anticipate that
something is going to happen but you
know what and to keep people engage in
the inner story another tip is when you
are writing the script put yourself in
the mind of the viewer I mean by the
time you are writing the script you are
an expert in the subject so even if you
choose to put an ad on in the script and
leave something out for you is very easy
to fill in the gaps because you already
know
listen but your audience doesn't because
they have they haven't done that
research so for me one of the most
critical things is when you are writing
the script and you decide to leave
something out or include something in
think about it that's really essential
for the story I mean if I leave this in
will help people that have no idea about
what I'm talking about follow the story
or they will get lost if it's something
essential definitely keep it in if it's
not essential take it out because TV
video as I said is not a medium that
allows a lot of information so try to
keep like the most important ideas in
the once that your audience needs to
follow the story and that is connected
to the next one don't try to explain
anything I mean there is a paradox at
the heart of science communication and
is regardless of the medium and is you
want to give an accurate view of reality
and at the same time you want to be
engaging so if you and at the same time
I will add do you have a limited amount
of time or you have a limited amount of
words if you were writing a story for a
magazine or a newspaper so the most
important task is what you live in the
story of what you take out of the story
and the hard part is there's no
algorithm there's no rule that is going
to help you figure out that I mean you
have to develop what I call mind-reading
abilities or I'm not a good criteria to
to follow is choose the ideas and plant
your storyline as if you knew nothing
about a subject what would you love to
hear and to see in
movie about a subject you have no idea
about you follow that criteria it will
help your securing out what to keep in
what to keep out and the last one is
don't underestimate your public don't
think that they are your audience is
stupid I mean actually there are many
topics in science that are complex if we
are talking about quantum physics it's
extremely complex so yes
embrace the complexity I mean not
everybody is going to understand
everything that you say I'm actually
it's fine because if everybody
understands everything probably what it
means is that you have simplified the
content way too much one of the main
ideas of science communication is it's
more important to ignite curiosity in
people and to help people ask questions
and leave them with questions so they
can after your movie or the documentary
or whatever you are producing I mean
help then go and get more information
about that than to give them all the
answers about everything
so a few indications about the style on
the script we mentioned that already a
stories are about people so we are very
used to read headlines like a studies I
study found that practice exercising
three times per week lowers the risk of
several types of cancer that's pretty
common actually it's a wrong a statement
because the studies don't find anything
people do science people run experiments
it's people the one the ones who
actually do science so again give the
core of your story to people also
because they pending on the topic you
choose people may be your audience may
not be interested in the topic but if
you put the focus in the people let's
frame it this way the way of keeping
your audience engaged in a topic is by
making them care about the people that
care about that topic if you are doing a
story about the mantis shrimp there is
an amazing animal in the ocean who has
amazing properties but you say I'm not
interested at all about the mantis
shrimp but you have very compelling
characters people will watch that movie
so even with our not very attractive
subject if you have compelling
characters people will watch your story
so definitely focus on the stories and
the people conflict and suspense those
are very powerful strategies to keep
people engage norway's is easy to find
conflict in science in wildlife films is
easy I mean a common way you're finding
conflict is fights between a predator
and a prey we have all of them seen that
kind of conflict in some other subjects
is trickier but many times you can find
that conflict in the process again let's
show the process of making science
because there you will find the
struggles and I don't know maybe the
fights between different teams for from
being the first one to discover
something so there you have the conflict
and suspense also it's a very powerful
as we said to will to actually generate
interest because it anticipates
something that you really don't know and
in the case of TV music is a very
powerful way of generating that sense of
suspense avoid jargon this is a big one
I mean scientists love inventing words
to communicate efficiently between them
the truth is that those words usually
work only for the people working in that
field even science is working in other
film don't understand those works so
common language has enough words to be
able to explain any topic in a way that
every single person can understand and
actually there is a very nice book
written by an astrophysicist his column
it's an Italian astrophysicist and the
book is called the edge of the sky and
it tells the story of the universe how
the universe was created and he made a
very interesting experiment was to
explain how the universe was created
using the
1000 most used words in English language
if we could made it anyone can make it
that said sometimes there's no way but
use jargon if that's the case
explain the concept first and then
include the word don't do it the other
way don't include first the word and
then explain the concept because until
your audience understands what you mean
with that word that word acts as a dead
weight that is going to pull down your
story so first explain what you mean and
then include the world avoid formality
science is also a very formal I mean the
scientific language is also very formal
and it's very structured and it's very
standardized but it drains passion I
mean I it's really hard to get
passionate when you were reading a
scientific paper right and when we are
producing a film or we are producing a
documentary what we really want is the
audience to experience anger to
experience fear to experience all the
possible emotions that humans can
experience so avoid formality to do that
and connected to that excuse me
connected to that don't use the passive
voice it's also very common to find
stories papers in science that use the
passive voice that also drains the
passion use the active voice that
doesn't mean that you have to speak in
the first person I that's actually not
good to do unless you have a very
powerful host
if you narrate something in the first
person you are putting yourself out
there like the most important part of
the scientific story actually is way
better to use the third person and let
the science be the main let's say
character of your story okay so those
are a few tips that I I wanted to share
with you I don't know how much time left
we have I would love to hear your
questions about it if you have any its
any of you going to film a movie for the
eureka film competition you are still
thinking about it
yeah yeah you can do it I mean I mean
it's possible for example I mean you
have to choose well your topic it has to
be something very specific I mean
obviously you cannot I mean you can make
a two minute video and without no
interviews to any people you can
interview them to gather information but
you cannot include I mean you don't have
to include any of them in your video if
you include some of some of them I will
recommend just include one I mean one of
the riskiest things what you are doing
the research is you can feel very
tempted to create a very long wish list
of people you will love to talk to and
that's perfectly fine you can talk with
as many people as you want but the thing
is that for the audience it's really
hard to get to know characters so even
if in a movie in a feature film and we
are talking about maybe half and one
hour and a half two hour long movie more
than seven or eight characters is too
much if we are talking about a
documentary usually four or five is the
limit I mean the shorter the video I
mean just one and then something also
very important that I didn't mention
talking about the expert something that
I have to deal every time in every
production when I reach out to assigned
everything that I contact a scientist
asking them okay I'm working on this
film or I'm working on this video and I
need a person to talk to me about X they
always tell you oh I'm going to
introduce you to this person there is
the person that knows the most about the
topic it's like actually I don't need
the person that knows them asked I need
the person that it's able to communicate
that subject
in an accessible way I mean the amount
of information again that you can share
on a chu man video or a one hour long
documentary is not that much so you
don't need the person that knows tons
about black holes or about CRISPR you
need a person that knows how to identify
the ideas that are key and to
communicate them in a way that is very
plain there is simple so can people
understand them my recommendation would
be don't use formulas and then use
numbers but if you have to use numbers
don't use digits just I mean if you yeah
don't don't use digits just make it
simple just make it simple I mean you
have to give information that has to be
grabs in in a second I mean when you are
it's tricky thing because every time
that you are explaining science and I
talk about that there is this paradox at
the heart of science communication you
want to be accurate but at the same time
you cannot explain everything because
you will run out of time and you will I
mean people will get lost and no one
will watch what you are producing and
many scientists I have found many
scientists who disagree with this
process of simplification because they
think that you are distorting reality
but I always love to mention actually
something that Carl Zimmer said once
talking about the tricks he uses for his
science writing is when we are creating
a firm or we are writing a story for a
newspaper or where we are on a radio
show the idea is not to create a replica
of reality the idea is to create a
well-made shadow of reality that ignites
curiosity in people so then people can
go and can read a book or can watch more
documentaries or can even meet the
experts in that field of expertise if
you have access to them and get a more
accurate view of that reality I don't
know if that helps you thank you
more questions
[Music]
said it but I would have thought develop
your script yeah I mean you cannot you
cannot have a detailed list of all the
shots that you will need for a fun
especially the longer the movie the
harder it is you just cannot plan every
single shot in a one hour long
documentary because you don't know what
it's gonna happen but do you need to you
need you need to get a list of the shots
that you need in order to tell that a
story I mean I have done that mistake in
the past of going out there without that
list and I start filming and then you
are in the editing room and you realize
oh I will need this shot and I didn't
get it so now you need to figure out how
to tell the story without that shot so
especially when especially with the core
ideas of your documentary I will
strongly say yes creating that and it
doesn't have to be a very detailed thing
I mean there I know people that create
storyboards and the storyboards are
droids and draws people draw what is
going to be in in each shot it's
impossible to do that in other
commentaries yes too long and it's
unpredictable I mean I cannot go to you
as an architect and tell you you have to
tell me exactly this I mean I don't know
what you are gonna tell even if I talk
to you on the research process many many
times again I mean science documentaries
per se have this very unpredictable
thing so having kind of a guideline
helps that's why I always recommend to
create a shot glass
that said there are people who don't do
it but usually it's only mind this kind
of making say a two-minute video it does
make sense yeah it's much more structure
exactly so I was very curious about the
point that you made about conflict yeah
so what what is it about being is it
really just engagement with the viewer
that conflict is needed for that or is
there some particular power to conflict
per se because you are resolving you're
providing an answer to some question or
a puzzle or riddle or something what is
it about conflict that works I think
it's both ways it's both things actually
I mean you don't really need people
fighting but I think that one of the
main powers of conflict comes from the
unexpected and yeah it's playing with
that actually it's it's it's quite
powerful yeah but I don't know how to
yeah I don't know how to how to explain
it but it's about finding and this is
also controversial it's like to try to
find outliers in in a story that help
like keep they keep the the audience
engage yeah it's about keeping the
tension it helps a little bit obviously
you can or all the time like go for it I
mean you have to know when use it want
to use it and whatnot I mean if you have
a wildfire phone all the time with
conflict between predator and prey that
could be boring I mean you will be
exhausted about it so but it's it's a
would where you're breaking the dynamic
of
firm and getting people interested again
it's like keeping the attention of
people is it useful to have a narrator
or a narrative should there be a voice
that it depends a lot on this story I
mean if the pencil of the story if you
have if you have compelling character I
will give I mean I will put that
character in a tip at the center of the
story if not if you have something super
powerful and a research idea there is
super powerful we found a new type of
star never seen or something like that
you don't really need a person I mean it
depends a lot on the subject but
definitely I will plan it because it's
just 2 minute so you have to have a very
clear idea of what you want to tell and
how you want to tell it and actually two
minutes is a lot of time it can't be a
lot of time it doesn't look like it but
it's a lot of time I mean you can
explain I mean I one of the shows that I
did once was explaining scientific it
was kind of a new show about science and
we have to explain scientific news every
day in one minute we only had one minute
and that story was was included in the
main news newscast and we only have 1
minute so we had to explain in one
minute and actually it's challenging but
it can be done yeah
making an animation is really hard and
[Music]
it's a it's it's a common element in
science documentaries animations I have
always worked with graphic designers to
create animations it's really hard
otherwise to I mean there's an there is
a technique that in the in the last few
years it has become more and more common
and it's about have you seen these
videos were doing separates from writing
on a whiteboard I mean I'm the whole
video is I mean a person that usually
draws very very well and has like a very
beautiful lettered and they draw they
hand draw the whatever scientific idea
you want to explain I mean that's
something that if you know how to draw
you could do it otherwise I mean it
takes a lot of time I mean one of the I
mean I have every time that I have to
explain a scientific concept what I
usually do is I draw myself what I want
to do and then I share that with an
animator and a graphic designers that
are the ones that create that on a
computer
actually it was a very expensive process
so that's why on porpoise I didn't
include it but also it depends it
depends on the on the on the subject
maybe you can become like super creative
and a final way to explain that idea
with some metaphors I mean something
that is also very powerful in science
communication is metaphors because
usually they work by reducing the
dimension of something into a scale that
is easier for people to understand so
for example a very common one is when
you explain the whole history of life on
Earth as it's was a process that
happened during one calendar year and
then I'm sure you have seen this at some
documentary and then you realize that it
in one calendar year humans will appear
in the surface of birds yes
I mean December 31st a few minutes
before the end of the year so those kind
of things can help and other techniques
that can help too but it's actually
trickier is to work with a stop motion
stop motion is a technique where
basically what you are doing is you are
taking shots pictures of something so
you create a set do you take a picture
you change tiny tiny tiny thing you take
another picture to tell only tiny tiny
thing you take another picture and then
in the editor room you put a little all
of it together
and then that that becomes some fun so
that's something that you could do too
but that requires higher skills so
basically the pencil are on their own
there you could create something if you
are a person that knows how to create
things if you are skill enough to build
something you could also do that
I mean I don't know any but I can check
I don't know any software that you can
use to create like super simple
animations yes okay yeah yeah I mean the
thing with when you are producing
something there is video format you have
all these elements that you can play
with it's not just the narration is the
image what actually you are seeing is
the sound I'm actually I mean the
combination of all of them correctly
helped without you having to create
something on a computer to explain an
idea I mean also one of the problems
that I have faces many times is that
when you are writing a piece for a
newspaper and you create one of these
amazing infographics it's you have you
can stop and really look at it and
understand
that when you are creating a documentary
again it's something that goes quickly
so the infographic has to be clear
enough so you can get it in a few
seconds and actually that makes it even
trickier so sometimes having something
that overlays in the footage that you
are using actually makes it even more
complex to understand so the narration
and maybe the images you use and the
sounds can make it work better than
using a complex graphic that that you
create poor self more questions okay so
I will share the document with with
Priya and yeah you can make it available
with anyone and yeah I mean I'm super
happy today to do that thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you